last night's Astros Dodgers World Series
game took over five hours and then la
lost crazy ya know usually when people
from Los Angeles enduro something for
five hours at least they get new breasts
out of it what am I so ver I looked down
and there was just nothing now usually I
got a nice rack out of it a mold breasts
Wow what else is going on
big story though that's not the story
today president Trump's former campaign
manager Paul Manafort was charged with
conspiracy against the United States
[Applause]
yeah apparently his conspiracy against
the United States was suggested to
Donald Trump that he run for president
now consider
that's now considered a crime yeah yeah
you really told to go no I don't know
take me away this is weird cuz you I
like to sometimes compare how you know
CNN is what CNN's broadcasting or MSNBC
versus Fox right how different it is
this morning while CNN and MSNBC were
covering the metaphoric indictments Fox
News did a story about the cheeseburger
emoji
that's true that's a real thing they did
just to keep you up-to-date that
cheeseburger emoji is still claiming it
did not collude with Russia to hijack
the election it had nothing to do with
it anything to be fair to Fox though I
still think that cheeseburger emoji is
probably now the best thing about our
country actual cheeseburger so
cheeseburgers slightly better yeah than
the emoji today another Trump advisor
george papadapolis pled guilty to lying
to the FBI about meeting with russians
in 2016 he pled guilty
the FBI would have issued an arrest
warrant sooner but they had a hard time
spelling Papadopoulos
oh they had the evidence on him two
years ago last week disgraced
Congressman Anthony Weiner that's his
name come on
let's grow up here it's the easiest guy
to do jokes about cuz I just report on
him and he's very giggling right last
week disgraced Congressman Anthony
Weiner was sentenced to a Medical Center
for sex offenders yeah yeah the other
sex offenders told Weiner hey it's nice
to finally put a face with the penis
it's nice actually to know
I'm terrible with penises big Olympic
news the IOC said they may consider
including pole dancing poker and
foosball in the next Olympic Games yeah
they also said it's the first Olympics
that will be held in a frat house
basement that was me doing a keg I was
not was not making ice cream my miming
sometimes I need to make it clear Arby's
that's right I said Arby's settle down
one guy not a great sign for Arby's man
well Arby's in the news 300 people in a
room one guy Arby's has responded to
critics of its venison sandwich saying
the deer meat was not obtained by
hunting yeah
Barbie said our deer meat is obtained by
driving
[Applause]
[Music]
catch and then bun on top yep
you